We also have dystopian news, not just from
the world of Donald Trump's taxes, but from
the world of the Supreme Court, because Donald
Trump has indeed nominated the Supreme Court
to the Supreme Court.
The Seventh Circuit judge who we reported
to you last week as the frontrunner.
Her name is Amy CONI Barrett.
I have clips from this completely authoritarian
nightmare event during which Donald Trump
nominated Amy CONI Barrett.
But I do want to remind you of a few things
before we get to that.
Last week in my segment about Amy CONI Barrett.
I told you that she is not merely a Federalist
Society type.
She's not merely an anti-abortion type.
She's not merely a it's all for God.
Even the legal system type.
I told you that she's part of a cult called
The People of Praise, which is reminiscent
of the cult that Margaret Atwood describes
in the dystopian novel A Handmaid's Tale.
And I got a few e-mails over the weekend from
people saying, you know, David, you have to
apologize, apologize because people of praise
was not actually the inspiration for Handmaid's
Tale.
That was fake news and you fell for it.
So let me clarify now.
No, no, no.
I didn't fall for anything.
I was very much aware last week that Handmaid's
Tale was inspired by a different group called
People of Hope.
I never said last week that People of Praise
was the inspiration for Handmaid's Tale.
I told you that there are some interesting
overlaps.
Barrett is part of people of praise, and there
are reminiscent elements of people of praise
that we see in Handmaid's Tale, for example.
People have praised previously referred to
women in the cult as Handmaids.
Now, they've since changed the name People
of Praise believes in the subjugation of women
in households.
As a matter.
Of default.
That's reminiscent of A Handmaid's Tale.
Yes.
People of Praise was not what inspired Margaret
Atwood's book.
But I never said that People of Praise was
what inspired Margaret Atwood's book.
So please stop asking me for apologies that
don't make any sense.
Now on to the event.
Donald Trump announced that, yes, Amy CONI
Barrett is his nominee to replace Ruth Bader
Ginsburg, putting in place a possible justice
who would close many of the doors that Ruth
Bader Ginsburg opened and left opened behind
her.
It's tragic.
It's nothing short of tragic.
So let's get into it.
Donald Trump here reading from a teleprompter,
the same type of teleprompter.
He slams Joe Biden for using making it official.
Amy CONI Barrett is his nominee to replace
are Biji.
Today, it is my honor to nominate one of our
nation's most brilliant and gifted legal minds
to the Supreme Court.
She is a woman of unparalleled achievement,
towering intellect, sterling credentials and
unyielding loyalty to the Constitution.
Judge Amy CONI Barrett.
So this really is horrible.
This is the exact opposite of the type of
person we should have on the court.
You look at other countries and you see other
countries moving forward.
We're moving backwards.
We're putting in more people who are against
abortion, people who believe that civil government
is a system meant to serve religious interests.
Amy CONI Barrett is saying that reportedly
when she spoke to Notre Dame at Notre Dame,
this could not be more dystopian and toxic
and the entire event was whacked.
Donald Trump here without even a semblance
of irony and no iota of hiring irony urges
lawmakers to refrain from personal attacks.
Thank you.
I further urge all members of the other side
of the aisle to provide Judge Baird with a
respectful and dignified hearing that she
deserves and frankly, that our country deserves.
I urge lawmakers and members of the media
to refrain from personal or partizan attacks,
and the stakes for our country are incredibly
high.
Yeah.
Donald Trump, who's been saying sleepy Joe
Biden has dementia and Truk Dutt took drugs
before his debate with Bernie and the same
Donald Trump that attacked Meghan Markle last
week that Donald Trump is saying don't make
personal attacks against Amy CONI Barrett.
Here is Barrett confirming that she is in
line with the ideology of the late right wing
Supreme Court Justice Antonin Scalia.
Absolutely horrifying and given has incalculable
influence on my life.
I am very moved to have members of the Scalia
family here today, including his dear wife,
Maureen.
I clerked for Justice Scalia and more than
20 years ago.
But the lessons I learned still resonate.
His judicial philosophy is mine, too.
So as I said last week, I do not believe that
at this point we have any way to stop this,
but we still do have things we can stop, like
another four years of Donald Trump.
This ship may have sailed if the Republicans
want to.
It's become clear because there are only two
Republicans that said they would not vote
to confirm a Supreme Court justice at this
time.
If they have the votes, they've they've had
the votes.
Now we'll see how the confirmation hearings
go.
You still do the confirmation hearings for
a reason.
But what we can stop is Trump getting more
Supreme Court justices.
Clarence Thomas is not a spring chicken at
this point.
It is likely that one, maybe two Supreme Court
justices would be replaced during the next
presidential term.
I don't want Donald Trump getting those selections.
I don't know if you do.
But from what we're seeing so far, I don't
think anybody should let me know your thoughts.
Let me know what you think the strategy should
be from here through the election.
I'm on Twitter
at
David Pakman,